in the European Union businesses are  heavily dependent on the money they can  borrow from their own national banks and  since the financial crisis has become  more difficult to get loans especially  for startups and small and medium  enterprises however capital can also  come from sources other than banks for  example from shares or bonds it's the  capital market more developed capital  markets mean more money for businesses  to invest and that means growth and jobs  we need to link money and entrepreneurs  remove barriers between a company a  small company based in for instance  Slovakia and capital available in say  Denmark we can't allow potentially  successful business ideas to fail just  because the market is too fragmented  free movement of capital is one of the  four fundamental principles on which the  EU was built here you finance ministers  are working on a project called capital  markets union to give businesses easier  access to capital across the EU